E aí
o
celular vai me engolir ela pegou
Concordo porque isso aqui vai me engolir
de uma forma que você vendo você
assistir doidas sabe cozinhar
tatatatatatata tatatatatatata
tatatatatatata
pegar tem que tomar cuidado para não
misturar as coisas vocês encontrarão
deseja para lá depois não sabe o que é
que é realidade o que é que é o que está
assistindo esse microfone as coisas e a
cabeça da pessoa fica doido de verdade
conversa é essa João Paulo João Paulo
quem é que tem mais controle da mente do
que eu nesse país eu sou praticamente
opinião dele bora rapaz deixa conversa
aí da hora essa bandeja aí que tu já
lavou a hora meu patrão tudo é
O
que é